dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on AFA here in the
world of digital 3d modeling it often
occurs that we are looking for surfaces
that are not perfectly smooth but have
some sort of surface detail wrinkles
engravings grain on a wooden table are
excellent examples of details that we
can add to our models and computer
graphics people like to collectively
call these things displacement maps
artists often encounter cases where they
like the displacements on one object but
the object itself is not really
interesting however it could be that
there is a different piece of geometry
these details would look great on
consider this problem solved because in
this piece of work the input is two 3d
models one with interesting geometric
details and the other is the model onto
which we transfer these surface details
the output will be our 3d geometric
shape with two of these models fused
together the results look absolutely
amazing I would love to use this right
away in several projects the first key
part is the usage of metric learning
weight technical term what does this
mean exactly metric learning is a
classical technique in the field of
machine learning where we are trying to
learn distances between things where
distance is mathematically ill-defined
let's make it even simpler and go with
an example for instance we have a
database of human faces and we would
like to search for faces that are
similar to a given input to do this we
specify a few distances by hand for
instance we could say that a person with
a beard is a short distance from one
with a mustache and the larger distance
from one with no facial hair if we hand
many examples of these distances to a
learning algorithm it will be able to
find people with similar beards and in
this work this metric learning is used
to learn the relationship between
objects with and without these rich
surface details this helps in the
transferring process as to creating the
new displacements on the new model there
are several hurdles to overcome
one we cannot just grab the
displacements and shove them onto a
different model because it can
potentially look different
have different curvatures and sizes the
solution to this would be capturing the
statistical properties of the surface
details and use this information to
synthesize new ones on the target model
note that we cannot just perform this
texture synthesis in 2d like we do for
images because as we project the result
to a 3d model it introduces severe
distortions to the displacement patterns
it is a bit like putting a rubber
blanket onto a complicated object
different regions of the blanket will be
distorted differently make sure to have
a look at the paper where the authors
present quite a few more results and of
course the intricacies of this technique
are also described in detail I hope some
public implementations of this method
will appear soon I would be quite
excited to use this right away and I am
sure there are many artists who would
love to create these wonderfully
detailed models for the animated films
and computer games of the future in the
meantime we have a completely overhauled
software and hardware pipeline to create
these videos we have written down our
joyful and perilous story of it on
patreon if you are interested in looking
a bit behind the curtain as to how these
episodes are made make sure to have a
look it is available in the video
description thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time
[Music]